on entame cette semaine une nouvelle
série de pages estivale dans le journal
de 19h après le loir-et-cher souterrain
la semaine dernière direction la
touraine pour des vacances sans stress
grâce aux déplacements doux et
aujourd'hui nous faisons du vélo à
chinon avec vous nathanaël le maire je
vois que vous êtes prêt à partir le
pique-niqué près aussi d'ailleurs
alors on a déjà circulé un petit peu ce
matin dans le vieux chinon pour une
visite avec un guide conférencier qui
nous a fait découvrir le patrimoine et
le vélo s'est révélée particulièrement
adapté pour circuler dans cette petite
ruelle de la ville de chinon
effectivement là nous allons partir en
pique nique duke dans le côté nature du
chinonais sur les bords de la vienne la
vienne qui coule derrière moi on est un
peu loin de la loire à vélo mais on voit
bien que le vélo permet bien sûr de
découvrir tout ce tout ce secteur
et puis un vélo particulier c'est des
vélos aux réformes et de la poste alors
très confortable et adapté au chemin du
chinonais et à l'emport du pique nique
comme vous pouvez le voir et on partira
donc avec vous sur les routes ce soir
dans le journal de 19h à ce soir
nathanaël